as guardians of the galaxy in the in the
morning guys we got ourselves the first
teaser trailer for thor love and thunder
and i said white boys wake up we gotta
do this assemble it's only 90 seconds
but we you both have to be here with me
that doesn't do that guys hit that subscribe
button because clearly it's worth it also leave
a like if you can that means the world i'm sure
there's a song in here that's going to get us
demonetized so we ask that you subscribe get us
closer to that million mark follow koi zhandra
over on tick tock covers a whole bunch of awesome
awesome possum stuff over there he'll be breaking
this video down as well specifically the real
rejects right now he'll be breaking down the thor
trailer my comic book expert you better be ready
ready because you recommend it yeah yeah let's do
these this were once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace hmm
wow i need to figure out simba exactly who i am
bearing junior man out of thunder man
i want to choose my own path live in
the moment yes guardians of the galaxy
my superheroing days are over what come on
man the goats the goat the goats of goats
you ever feel lost on the people that you love
not me just listening where's jane
oh there she
yeah that is looks great the mighty thor indeed
that was absolutely a lot in 90 seconds yeah
i love that they're leaning into the color palette
so so much like the 80s thor costume is kind of a
running commentary on marvel comics like there's
that phase that we don't usually talk about
they're like making it cool which is what tyka
does and that's what taka does best man yeah and
speaking of 80s i actually really love the choice
to use the song sweet child of mine sweet child of
mine while like a good like a really cool 80s love
rock song towards the latter part of that song
they have that melody like where do we go now
where do we go so what will be the future of
our relationship there's some like questioning
happening there i feel like that kind of works
on both levels with this particular trailer his
relationship with being thor his relationship with
being a hero his relationship with being himself
like where do we go now obviously in this trailer
you hear him saying what was my path is here what
do i continue to do and also when you do have jane
in here as mighty thor where in the comics correct
me the room unless i put it in the comments i mean
i did read it but in the comics jane uh
she's diagnosed with cancer through a variety
of circumstances she's able to suddenly
wield the power of thor use michelle nor
magellan correctly so americans are supposed to
say it yeah use milner but every time she actually
activates herself decreases the progress of the
chemotherapy within the cancer right so she's
fighting it's weaker every time she uses it i
feel like this song used in here works on so many
levels even though we didn't get to that part in
the song but i know that's what the song goes that
song choice not only encapsulates the 80s feel to
it but also thematically what thor as a character
is going through here of what should he do for
his future especially in regards himself and
especially in regards to jane as well it's a song
that harkens to some kind of uh you know coming of
age which it seems like thor's in a new phase of
doing what do i do now that i've sort of hung up
my warrior lifestyle and i'm trying to live
something that's more sort of bless you mighty koi
i just love the way it complemented the colors
and the scope you know like these movies have
tons of scope especially the thor movies being the
sort of epic interpolations that they are but this
one definitely looks like it's bringing in sort
of a different flavor to that visual aesthetic
like it doesn't look like as much of a big epic
battle movie though those things will come and
i'm excited to see what the contrast is in the
storyline here because they're not leading with
a ton of action a ton of fighting we don't even
get a glimpse of gore the god butcher in a very
distinct way that i could notice so i like that
this is mostly honing in on where's thor now
and where do we go from here i love that it is
not only the 80s aesthetic with thor and that
is his way of going on a walkabout i feel like
what he's embracing as thor is his more fun like
his truthful self it's a it's literally like
an australian walkabout story but we're also
expanding the world in doing that we got a quick
shot of zeus played by russell crowe we also got
you know our entire guardians of the galaxy
so the scope of this is really big but i
think the details we get the goats the two
the ghost tooth nasher and tooth grinder
that's right tooth dasher tooth grinder but i do
also think the mjolnir reassembled was interesting
because we saw him bury stormbreaker which is the
last ax and and hammer we saw him wield but we saw
hella destroy mjolnir and then it looks like
it got reassembled to a clay pot yeah so she's
wielding the reassembled mjolnir so i'm wondering
if like you know maybe she's more worthy maybe she
through you know becoming thor it
reassembled cosmically and what does
that mean for stormbreaker what does that mean
for that journey between them what does that
mean for their relationship because it's only a
minute and a half trailer and we see him you know
dancing around this pirate sherman so there's
clearly something with someone else and then
thor comes back this is disney's replacement for
pirates of the caribbean this is it right there
that's how we do it we also saw our new king
of asgard yeah valkyrie and dealing with local
politics looks like she is hating dealing with
local politics so much it's the little glimpse you
get over her just she looks bored out of her mind
the parks and rec section of the show strong being
a warrior so i imagine doing like political [ __
] is not really what she actually wants to do but
she but she wants to tend to the people you know
so i'm interested to see what the bureaucracy is
going on in new asgard is and what all the effects
post endgame of everything that's happening there
like to kind of unpack i also i'm really excited
for the inevitable 80s action montage if i'm
losing the weight that we got sampled here yeah
the chain scene that i imagine is gonna be a full
sequence of him dropping from fat thornton mighty
thing and then into her being mighty thor but
also his hat saying strongest avenger because
that's the argument of hulk was it sakara 1.2
yeah that's what i'm wondering because the the
strongest avenger hat felt very pointed in many
directions why would they go back to car though
um maybe to pick up jeff goldblum i don't know
but jeff goldblum is is currently crashing with
daryl is he right yeah maybe they went to look
for him and they're like ah he's gone well
we should just clean this up while he's away
so that you know when he gets back he won't
be pissed yeah that's it it would be great
to have a daryl cameo though i think daryl should
finally make it into the news carol has earned it
i think daryl has fought long and hard and it's
time best friend hero man team daryl thor looks
great what a beast of a human being like how does
he always find a way to get larger it is insane
and i and i like what you were saying about about
the 80s vibe and the sort of commentary that the
comics bring in on the aesthetics and stuff every
different generation and iteration because i feel
like we're at a fortunate time for that with the
movies because we have such a prevalence of 80s
nostalgia within our pop culture so i feel like
this movie has the opportunity to both poke fun
at certain aspects of you know the comic runs
of the 80s and how those could be perhaps silly
by today's standards but also to legitimize some
of those things to take something that might have
been silly and make it actually kind of legitimate
or cool i think this has the chance to make some
of the worst ever thor stories the coolest ever
thor stories because that wrestling outfit is
among the worst costumes of all time
in comic books it's on many lists of
how did this happen and if anyone's gonna make
it cool it is the handsomest and the tykist and i
feel like the guardians will probably only just be
probably in the like the first act of this movie
the first act but i think they're going to be a
big part of it for a while while they're in it
it's going to be integral yeah yeah and especially
his relationship with star-lord himself it seems
like that's the main thing they'll be honing in
on what was cool about this was as much as we're
getting in here it still feels like it's very
thor centric what i found kind of interesting
is that there's a melancholic vibe to it the
last thor movie was just so funny like it was so
fun so entertaining there's a lot more to it than
that but that was like the main takeaway here you
get a little bit more of the shades of the jojo
rabbit taika ytd in terms of its more dramatiy
effect like you can just feel that underneath the
surface which i thought was really cool i feel
like it's gonna be more character driven a little
bit more deep and nuanced than thor ragnarok even
was maybe this will be our thor means death that's
more my preference honestly i like when he's got
a darkness to his comedy and and not in the david
fincher sense but in the morose uh coping quality
because you know the world can be dark so if you
look at the the trajectory of the avengers films
you've got captain america going from self less to
selfish through literally diving on a bomb to like
you know sacrificing everything to go be with his
peggy then you've got tony stark going from a man
who's warmongering to eventually landing as the
guy that does jive on the bomb and saves us all so
their arc is very specific and the x of their arc
is civil war the only movie that we didn't have
thor in because thor's entire arc is being certain
of self and then losing sense of self we've not
landed on where that loss of sense of self is
so we've had the trajectory for the other two of
the big three we've had those landings thor's the
only one that remains and we've had him have more
and more of a crisis of self as the movies get
bigger so i'd love a more sorrowful conclusion to
understand what thor wants to be and what better
way to do that than have the reflection of self
and jane foster and perhaps his successor
you sound so stupid i just stuff you like
listen don't subscribe to koi's
channel don't just take tacos
don't you wait secret goddamn time
you guys can subscribe to us though
leave a like and it's my last time done with thor
love and thunder down below catch you guys soon